the Swiss court has just sentenced a
writer to two months in jail for calling
an LGBT activist a fat lesbian the
writer was found guilty of defamation on
Monday and the verdict was immediately
praised by the lesbian activist Group
Los as quote an important moment for
justice and rights of lgbtqi people in
Switzerland which
means well he was found guilty of defam
for calling her a
lesbian and the verdict was praised as a
victory for lesbian
rights so I I don't think that men
should ever call women
fat and I don't think men even should
ever call women lesbians
but if the victory is a if the verdict
rather is a victory for lesbian rights
then that implies that the victor was a
lesbian which means that he did not
defame her he was just sort of impolite
which is not good but does an impolite
remark really Merit 60 days in jail well
if the impolite remark happens also to
be politically incorrect then apparently
the answer is yes because as that same
lesbian activist group pointed out quote
the conviction of this writer is a
strong signal that homophobic hatred
cannot be tolerated in our
society it wasn't even what he said if
the writer had purple hair and 10
piercings and said this woman is an
empowered fat lesbian if he had used the
exact same phrase in a positive way he
would probably be given an award he
certainly wouldn't be in jail but he
used the phrase with appr probium he
seemed to disapprove of
lesbianism that's the crime he's going
to jail for and soon enough you might be
too I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode brought to you by good ranchers
get great meet at a secure price and 25
bucks off your order with code nolles
wle I had juicy delicious good ranchers
just a couple of days ago two three days
ago it was marvelous as always go to
goodranchers.com use code NES
today the LA Unified School District is
about to host a week-long celebration of
coming out day no longer a day now a
week we'll get to that in just one
moment first though I'm still wrapping
my mind around this if you say the
phrase in
Switzerland she that wonderful person is
a fat Les lesbian let's hear it
everybody woo and then you all applaud
that's great but if you say hey she that
lady that I don't like she's a fat
lesbian you go to
jail with the same thing you go to jail
for having a politically incorrect
opinion and what's really bizarre about
it is the opinion you go to jail for is
the opinion that was until very recently
held by everyone which is that doing
weird sex stuff is not ideal it's not
the thing we ought to strive for but
this is spreading throughout the old
world speaking of people living in the
old world getting arrested for things
for saying things uh Lawrence Fox who
ran for mayor of London he's an actor
who then got into politics he ran for
mayor of London he founded the reclaim
party he's a conservative totally
mainstream conservative commentator and
political activist until recently he had
a show on GB news in the
UK cops just raided Lawrence's house and
arrested him for speaking out against
the London mayor's new climate
surveillance cameras all over the city
coming off
to what look how many coppers there are
in my house look at them coming to steal
everything take everything out of my
house that ladies and gentlemen is the
country that we live in see all these
cops here rating Lawrence's Lawrence for
the Le dangerous person in the United
Kingdom all raiding his his place
because he said that the mass
surveillance cameras as part of Mayor
sadik
Khan's climate change initiative to spy
on all the citizens he he spoke out
against those cameras and so they raid
his his apartment he he explains what
the the whole issue is about guys um in
London's knife ridden capital city where
a 15-year-old girl was stabbed to death
with a sword we've got one two you can
show them one
two another three
upstairs stealing going through my house
to intimidate me because um this is what
the police are they don't please with
consent anymore they police with fear
and intimidation that is the starszy
police force that we've got nowadays
instead of being on the streets solving
crimes like the murder of the poor
15-year-old girl they're on all over
social media but I'd take it the um ules
scam cameras outside of London are a
complete the out of ues zone is a
complete scam there's no scientific
evidence sadique Khan rubbished the
evidence and had it Rewritten to serve
his own needs no one voted it it's the
beginning and bringing in of a
surveillance State and he's trying to
make noises so that I can't say that
it's the beginning of a surveillance
State and these boys are the starszy sad
starszy bless them so have a lovely day
day I'm going to spend my day in the
clink in
it I love the British generally but
especially guys like Lawrence who even
as they're being raided by the cops
about to be hauled off to prison for a
thought crime they can stay relatively
buoyant I'm to spend my day in the clink
in it and and it it's funny because you
got to either laugh or cry the London
mayor sending his goons to go arrest a
political rival for speaking out against
his climate change BS surveillance
program the same exact sort of thing we
see when Joe Biden says his his goons
out to arrest his political opposition
in Donald Trump on a bunch of trumped up
pun very much intended ridiculous
charges it's not just happening in
America it's not just happening in
Britain this sort of thing it's not just
happening in Switzerland it's this sort
of thing is happening all over the West
which is why I think sometimes in the US
we are little myopic reviewing these
things in too narrow a way even some
conservatives sometimes do they say oh
our political dysfunction it's just
because Donald Trump is kind of
eccentric it's not just about Trump yes
Donald Trump is a unique American
original no doubt about it but the
election of Donald Trump didn't happen
in a vacuum it happened within the
context of the brexit it happened within
the context of the rise to power of
Victor orbon in Hungary it happened in
Georgia Maloney on a conservative
populist wave in Italy it happened with
populist waves Rising not totally to
fruition yet in Spain rising in Germany
Rising elsewhere as well people have had
enough of the liberal Crackdown
surveillance State globalist nonsense
and you're seeing that expressed
everywhere and and so as the people
begin to push back against that then the
government is going to crack down even
harder not just by trumping up your
charges not just by calling you an
insurrectionist not just by uh finding
all sorts of little areas to nitpick and
prosecute you selectively while they let
their own friends off the hook they're
going to go after you for Thought crimes
they're going to arrest you for having
the wrong opinions that is already
happening speaking of crime is a story
about a left-wing activist who was
living in Brooklyn in a bad part of the
city he was out with his girlfriend very
late at night you know very bad part of
the city that white guys wearing fancy
suits should certainly not be walking
around in at 4:00 a.m. you're going to
be a little bit conspicuous and he was
stabbed he was stabbed to death uh he
bravely stood between the attacker and
his girlfriend uh he probably unwisely
was in that place at night and seemed to
walk toward this Maniac who was causing
a ruckus further down the block so
errors of judgment there a demonstration
of courage
but now we're back to seeing errors of
judgment from the this poor slain man's
friends according to the Daily Mail
friends of this 32-year-old murder
victim uh say that his being murdered in
bedy at 4 in the morning would not
change his outlook on social justice
they say quote I know he would have
wanted people to use his death as a
means to talk about structural wrongs in
the city I'm absolutely positive that he
would immediately see that this was a
person who was suffering from a lack of
resources in our community who probably
needs better mental health support
possibly housing possibly drug support
drug treatment what he would want to
avenge his death is for us to fix how
broken this system is according to New
York State Assembly member Emily
Gallagher this is a reminder of a line
from Robert Frost which is that a
liberal is one who can't take his own
side in a
quarrel that is the definition of a
liberal and this is not a good attitude
people think this is a good attitude
because it's seems so altruistic it
seems so selfless but it's it's a
perversion of of a virtue which is
charity and it's a perversion of that
virtue because it it totally disregards
the proper love of oneself one has to
have a proper love of oneself and a a
proper inclination towards
self-preservation the reason for that is
we are called to love our neighbor as
ourselves if we don't love ourselves
then we can't love our neighbor as we
love our or we won't love our neighbor
much at
all this is related to a modern liberal
misconception that we can't have any
enemies we got to pretend that no one
wants to do us harm that no one is our
enemy that no one has different
interests than we do that no one could
possibly act in an unjust way no we got
to ignore we're all just friends Kumbaya
hold hands that is not true and there's
there's nothing Christian about that
that is a perversion of
Christianity we have
enemies we need to know who our enemies
are we need to have a very cleare eyed
view of our enemies because we are
called to love our enemies and so we
have to love our enemies we have to pray
for those who persecute
us but if you don't know who your
enemies are then you don't know who to
love if you if you are in denial about
who is persecuting you who is trying to
harm you who is acting in an unjust way
against you then you can't pray for them
you can't love
them Christianity is not a denial of
reality Christianity is not a burying
your head in the sand about the the
facts of this life quite the opposite
Christianity is looking looking at this
world in brutal honesty looking at the
fallenness of this world with brutal
honesty and then looking Beyond this
world and having hope as a theological
virtue and a fact Beyond this world but
but it's not a denial liberalism is the
denial of reality liberalism is the
denial of human nature liberalism is the
denial of original sin liberalism often
amounts to the denial of redemption and
so everything gets screwy and everything
goes out of place but if if we want to
help other people we have to have a
proper love of ourselves and and at
least an inclination to preserve
ourselves and if if we want to love our
enemies we have to know who our enemies
are we have to have some clear sense of
justice when you want to do do right by
your body when you want to do right by
your dinner table you got to check out
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code noes we
all have a lot on our schedules with how
much we've got to do every single day
you got to take your kids to sports you
got science fears you're prepping for
the holidays well the good news is you
can take one big thing off your plate by
putting great meat on your plate with
good ranchers you care about what your
family eats so does good ranchers that
is why they've spent years building
relationships with local farms to Source
the best 100% American beef chicken pork
and now wild caught Seafood the best of
the land and sea can be delivered
directly to your door I just I just
adore good ranchers they're currently
offering two years of free ground beef
to anyone who subscribes which is a $480
value and insane they'll also lock in
your uh price for two years which is in
insane especially with high inflation
right now they guarantee you 100%
American Meat it is by far the best in
the business it's not even close when I
was a kid stake was a very special
occasion kind of thing now you can have
stake delivered to your door for your
whole family for an incred low price use
code nesg goodranchers.com for 25 bucks
off and free ground beef for 2 years
remember to subscribe to any box to lock
in your price on America's best meat
goodranchers.com promo code NES canas
for over $500 in savings subscribe to
good ranchers American Meat delivered
speaking of important lessons there's a
seventh grade
teacher who has just gone viral on Tik
Tok for explaining how his fourth grade
how his seventh grade students are
reading at a fourth grade level so I'm
not really understanding why they not
telling y'all like we all know that the
world is behind like you know globally
like you know because of the pandemic
and stuff but I don't understand why
they not stressing to y'all how bad it
is like I'm not even trying to be funny
but these kids
are I'm going just say this I teach
seventh grade they are still performing
on the fourth grade
level I don't care how you flip it turn
it swing swing it Swindle it they still
performing on a fourth grade level a
nobody talking about how they just keep
moving passing them on they just keep
passing passing them passing them
passing them on passing them passing
them passing them I can put as many
zeros in this as I want to they going to
move that child to eth grade next year
ain't nobody talking about that why they
not talking about that why they not
telling y'all that Y and why don't y'all
know that y'all kids not performing on
that great level why I don't know this
why yall don't know I really like this
guy I like I know he's he's speaking in
a way that's a bit unusual you know but
he's observing a true problem and he's
saying why why aren't they letting you
know this these kids are completely
failing and and they're not going to be
left
behind
because the liberal governing
structure would rather deny reality and
fail these kids and put us all in a
worse situation then acknowledge that
there's a problem and that and that they
themselves have failed to teach students
and try to fix that problem so that the
kids are actually brought up to the
level at which they should be
reading you're not helping any you're
not doing anybody favors by denying
reality you're not doing anybody any
favors by pretending that they are
succeeding when they are
failing you you are compounding the
problem you're going to make the problem
worse for everybody you're going to make
the problem worse for all of society
because believe it or not even in our
highly ideological age societies still
require some degree of competence in
order to function we live in an age
where we think that as long as you have
the right opinion this is on the left
and even on the right as long as you
just have the right opinion everything's
going to be fine but that's not true the
the the grain mills are not going to
keep on churning just because you have
the right opinion about some LGBT issue
the trains are not going to keep moving
the traffic lights are not going to go
from green to Red the the airplanes are
not going to keep flying in the sky the
the basic functions of
society the sanitation workers are not
going to keep keep things
flowing just because you have the right
opinion about some obscure ideological
fashion people need to know basic things
the society needs to know how to how to
read at least the people running Society
need to know how to read they know how
to do math they need to know how to do
math they need to know how to I don't
know change a tire you really like basic
stuff if if a society can't do that it
doesn't matter how many high fu opinions
it has it's not going to flourish it's
not going to function some of this is
existential we're seeing a lot of things
break down right now we're seeing the
economy begin to break down we're seeing
Supply chains break down we're seeing
food break down we're this is this was
exacerbated by coid but it's been a
long-standing trend we're not we're not
functioning at the level that we need to
be
functioning and that problem does not
begin when you elect Joe Biden it's
exacerbated when you elect Joe Biden but
that problem begins when you when you
just keep graduating these people from
the seventh grade to the eighth grade
when they don't know how to do the
fourth grade
material that's going to exacerbate
crime problems it's going to exacerbate
poverty problems it's going to
exacerbate problems of government
because people aren't going to know how
the government
operates it's going they're not going to
know how to vote they're not going to
know when they're being taken advantage
of by
demagogues if the citizenry doesn't
understand basic things how is the
government going to function when we are
supposedly a self
government speaking of kids turning now
to Los Angeles La Unified School
District is about to host a weeklong
celebration of coming out
day you might think from the name that
they would have a dayong celebration at
most no it's a week now soon it will be
a month it already is a month because
they have the month of June which is
pride month and then they have October
which we're in right now that's LGBT
history month so they've already got one
sixth of the calendar year probably
they're going to add another month and
then they'll have a quarter of the year
and eventually they'll have the whole
year long
LAUSD has said uh that they'll have this
weekl long coming out celebration
according to City Journal a teacher
within the district shared a document
called the week of action toolkit
Elementary which outlines how L USD
would treat the month of October as
another lgbtq month not week of action
toolkit High School not week of action
toolkit middle school week of action
toolkit Elementary
School these teachers should
[Music]
be the answer to that is not let's get
sex out of the classroom they're going
to read some story about a family
they're going to read uh some story some
story about changes in the nature of the
family threat
history they're going to they're going
to get some morals and some ethics
what's it going to be right now for a
full week probably a full month probably
two months out of the year it's going to
be LGBT
propaganda as long as conservatives say
well I just want to remain neutral
they're going to continue they're going
to take another three months and you
will not rest easy if you've got your
kids in these schools which is one way
to improve your sleep would be to check
out Helix sleep right now go to
helixsleep.com with everything going on
in the world right now you could really
use a good night's sleep that is why you
need to check out Helix mattress the
Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses
including the award-winning Lux
collection oo la la the newly released
Helix Elite collection a mattress
designed for Big and Tall sleepers and
even a mattress made just for kids I
have had my Helix for years probably
what three four years now I absolutely
love it night after night I sleep so
sweet so sound I want the same for you
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress why would you want to
sleep in a mattress made for someone
else get out of my mattress I'm a
married man go to helixsleep.com
KW take their two-minute sleep quiz to
find the perfect mattress for your body
and sleep type their flexible payment
plans make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away Helix offers 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners helixsleep.com
use code Helix partner 2020 this is
their best offer yet it won't last long
Helix better sleep starts now
if you are watching convicting a
murderer you've already seen many
instances where making a murderer
skillfully curates information to align
with their narrative get ready to dive
into their most egregious manipulation
yet that's right we're talking about the
infamous blood vial the one that was
supposedly used to plant Steven Avery's
blood in the victim's car but here's the
catch making a murderer conveniently
omitted a crucial detail that completely
unravels that insane Theory huh you're
not going to want to miss this in-depth
look at how so many viewers were tricked
episode seven is now available on
dailywire plus take a
look coming up on convicting a murderer
they have Brendon on the police station
why something to do with you the police
did not have Brendan dassi on their
radar at all Caleb brings up that they
should talk to her cousin Brendan they
initially went down to that high school
because they were worried about him
because his cousin made some comments
about him losing weight she mentioned
things like staring off in the space and
weight loss she estimated to be about 40
lb they thought that maybe he had had
seen something and he was having trouble
dealing with what he had witnessed you
should have said to them I want my mom
in there yeah you definitely can see how
someone like him was easily manipulated
I really feel sorry for Brendan getting
roped into some scheme that Steven
decided he was going to come up with we
did not expect what he was telling
[Music]
us new episodes of convicting and
murderer are released every Thursday
exclusively on dailywire plus if you're
not a member head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to sign up today
speaking of harmful stuff being foed on
kids and adults I got a message
yesterday after I covered a report that
anti-depressants are having all sorts of
weird sexual uh consequences on people
this is the message I got I found your
video on anti-depressants very
interesting you had mentioned that
teenag will never develop sexual
function and you're correct I'm
currently dealing with permanent side
effects from an SSRI and I would
encourage you to check out this website
as what you said in your video
correlates to the problem so I clicked
on the link and it it took me to a
website about a condition called
pssd a condition of of these
consequences that affect sex and
emotions and really the whole
personality not just while people are on
these SSRI drugs but after they get off
them sometimes permanently long after
they get off the SSRI drugs and no one
seems to be talking about this one in
eight American adults is hooked on SSR I
drugs and I I don't even need to qualify
it necessarily with among adults because
increasingly these drugs are being
prescribed to teenagers and kids even
12-year-olds a huge number of Americans
are on these drugs there was a study
that came out some months ago that
suggests that the drug drugs don't work
in the way that we've been told that the
drugs work no one really knows how the
drugs work but we are seeing increasing
evidence that these these powerful
psychiatric drugs that a huge number of
Americans are on can have permanent
consequences and totally rewire people's
personalities post SSRI sexual
dysfunction or pssd is the current term
used to describe this phenomenon tssd
can manifest as a wide range of
neurological physical and sexual
symptoms among the most common symptoms
reported by sufferers are genital
numbness erectile dysfunction vaginal
dryness a complete loss of libido an
orgasmia emotional blunting anhedonia
and cognitive impairment these and many
more debilitating symptoms can persist
for years decades or even become
permanent after discontinuing the
medication despite the acknowledgement
by various healthc Care organizations
that sexual side effects can persist
many suff sufferers still have their
symptoms minimized and dismissed as a
valid Health Care concern currently
there is no effective treatment for pssd
and tragically some severely affected
patients have taken their lives so the
there are two keys to me here about this
explanation one this is not just some
cook Fringe theory of of people who are
ascribing consequences to this this drug
that aren't really there this is
something that's acknowledged by the
European medicine agency by the na s by
all sorts of Public Health bodies
they're saying yes yeah these drugs can
cause all these issues and they cause
all these sexual issues which is bad
enough sex is very important to human
nature and so if you totally blunt sex
especially in super young people
especially in teenagers can you imagine
how awful that would be but then beyond
that what about the emotional blunting
what about the anhedonia the inability
to feel pleasure what about the
cognitive impairment that comes from
these powerful psych drugs because
people don't want to engage in ordinary
therapy someone says oh you know I'm
feeling a little bit sad today uh rather
than engage in cognitive behavioral
therapy rather than talking to a
counselor or to a priest rather than
addressing the the spiritual concerns or
just the Practical everyday issues that
might be causing someone to feel a
little sad what does our culture do our
culture says oh good take a magic pill
yeah take this drug get hooked on drugs
and it might melt your brain and it
might screw up entire sexuality and it
might deprive you of the ability to feel
pleasure or to think for the rest of
your life but hey at least then we don't
need to confront the problem just take a
pill and no one's talking about this
that's insane the the public health
bodies are acknowledging that this is a
problem no one talks about it the the
rates of prescription just keep going up
we start prescribing it to 12-year
olds
absolute
Madness i a a simple question might be
we're living in an age of marked sexual
dysfunction there's always weird sex
stuff throughout all of history but
we're living in a time where people no
longer know the meaning of the
[Music]
word speaking of
shifts we're now Shifting the Speaker of
the House of
Representatives and someone who I
thought was not going to enter the race
did enter to the race that is Steve
scales I KN I knew Steve scales was
interested in the job he's been on the
track for house leadership for many
years now but Steve scales has had some
health problems in recent years some
crazy Bernie bro leftist uh tried to
murder him at the Congressional baseball
game and shot him and he had a long
recovery nearly killed him and Steve
scal also has been diagnosed with cancer
so I I thought he just was going to not
have the uh band with to to be the
speaker of the house but he's a tough
guy and he says he's going to do it
anyway so Steve scales is running for
speaker speaker Jim Jordan is also
running for speaker you know love love
Jim Jordan he was he was on the show
somewhat recently he and I played face
off together you can catch that on
YouTube uh Jim I I've long thought would
make an excellent speaker of the house
and the only reason I hadn't encouraged
him to run for it is because I like him
too much and I don't wish so terrible a
job on him uh but these are both good
guys these are both good good uh options
I I'm personally uh you know favorably
inclined to Jim Jordan I just I just
know him better and uh you know I think
he'd be very good but Steve scales could
be a good speaker too uh unfortunately
Donald Trump the man who many of us were
pulling to be speaker he's not
interested who should be
speaker should be speaker who should be
speaker Mr President a lot of people
have been calling me about speaker all I
can say is we'll do whatever is best for
the country and for the Republican party
people say we have some great great
people would you take the job a lot of
people have asked me about it I'm
focused you know we're leading I don't
know you I'm sure you don't read too
much in the papers so we're leading by
like 50 points for president you know my
focus is totally on that if I can help
them during the process I would do it
but we have some great people in the
Republican party that could do a great
job as Speaker what Taylor green called
for you to be speaker yesterday did you
st I think she's a wonderful
woman a lot of other
that too I'll do whatever it is to help
but my focus my total focus is being
president and why honestly making
America great again because we are
living in a country in Decline this is
the country that's failing badly we're
not respected in the world interest
rates are through the roof taxes are
through the roof inflation is horrible
but it's done to us it's eating Us Alive
okay so Trump's not going to be speaker
no one really thought that he was going
to be speaker my takeaway from that
answer though is not just that he
doesn't want the job of course he
doesn't it's the worst job in Washington
my takeaway is not just that he wants to
be president he does want to be
president my takeaway is counter to what
a lot of consultant class Republicans
will say and what the Liberals will say
Donald Trump has excellent message
discipline get to that in one second
first though it's officially October
there's no hiding it pumpkin spice
season is upon us and I'm I'm that life
man I'm embracing it I Am Em bibing I am
fully in the PSL lifestyle and you can
be too here it is you go to
dailywire.com shop you get your hands on
the limited edition Michael NES pumpkin
spice candle this is everything that you
need to complete the trifecta and eat
drink and breathe pumpkin spice like the
white girl living inside of you I don't
care if you're the biggest fattest
Hispanic man you're a a you got you got
a white girl living inside of you just
waiting to get out okay don't wait order
your candles now they are only available
during pumpkin spice season only
available at daily.com
shop it's good my favorite comment
yesterday is from Dark Avenger
424 who says Alex Jones for speaker I
guess I hadn't even considered it that
might be the greatest option because
then you could have the speaker the
leader of Congress and the
insurrectionists from January 6th they
could become the same people you could
have Alex Jones introducing the horn hat
guy to give a speech on the floor of the
house ladies and gentlemen before we get
to the president ladies and gentlemen
before we get to the State of the Union
I would introd like to introduce to you
the shaman and then the shaman could go
out and he'd make a hell of a lot more
sense than Joe Biden does damning with
faint praise but still no question about
it that would be that would be
great Donald
Trump surprisingly contrary to what so
many people will have you believe has
excellent message discipline when he was
asked will you be the speaker of that so
thank you I'm happy to help but no I'm
not I'm running for president I'm up 50
points so we always hits I'm I'm up I'm
leading I'm the number one guy I've got
the nomination but it's not just that he
then goes further and he says he just
launches into a stump speech he says the
economy is terrible and everything under
Joe Biden's awful and families are
hurting and the borders open and
whatever the parts of his stump speech
are he launches right into it he never
misses an opportunity to hammer home the
four or five points on which his
campaign is built which which
contradicts something we've been told
about Trump which is that he's a
demagogue Donald Trump is not a
demagogue Donald Trump for all of his
sins for all of his flaws for all of his
eccentricities is kind of the opposite
of a demagogue a demagogue is one who
totally changes his message based on
what group he's speaking
to a demagogue is like uh Peron one
Peron down in Argentina or for a more
modern American example Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton could go into any room and
he could charm the pants off everybody
and he could have everybody believing
that he agrees with them Barack Obama
does the same thing Barack Obama wants
bragged he said that in politics he
could go into a room and make everyone
in that room even if they have different
views think that he was on their side
that's not Trump trump can offend people
even who are on his side but he's going
to stick to his message every one of his
speeches is the same thing we got to
stop the immigration we got to build the
wall we got to have trade tariffs we've
got to make America great again this is
a country in Decline he just hits the
same points no matter who he's talking
to he could be talking to a a crowd at
the Maga Auditorium or he could be
talking to his grandmother he's going to
stay the same thing and he's focused and
he he's clearly running as though he's
already clinched the nomination he's
running for the general now could he
could he we see an upset in Iowa
maybe wouldn't count on it Trump is
still leading in Iowa among committed
delegates I think it's something like
two to one over his next rival Des
santis but maybe maybe the disantis
campaign puts everything into Iowa and
they pull an upset in Iowa they would
have to do the same in New Hampshire
which doesn't look POS possible because
I think the S antis is four or five in
New Hampshire now so maybe I don't know
let's say Nikki Haley pulls an upset in
New Hampshire okay and then you get down
to South Carolina who knows maybe Tim
Scott maybe Nikki Haley pull an upset in
South Carolina and then what's going to
happen in Florida probably Trump is
going to win Florida I don't know maybe
just maybe disantis wins Florida I don't
know then you go to Nevada almost
certainly Trump is going to win Nevada I
just for for all of these
campaigns I just don't see how this ends
up any different than it did in 2016
there were there were all these moments
when Cruz could have won it or Rubio
could have won it or Kasich probably not
Kasich but somebody could have won it
and it just it just never materialized
and I don't see that any difference now
other than that Trump is up by even more
than he was back then uh speaking
of
politicians the new California Senator
lefa
Butler she was the one immediately named
by governor Patrick baitman uh to fill
the seat vacated when Diane Feinstein
died she is the president of em EMILY's
List EMILY's List is a group that works
to elect pro-abortion women to public
office so she's a real she's a treat you
know this one her rais on Detra the the
uh thing that gets her out of bed in the
morning is just getting women elected
who are going to be more inclined to
murder babies uh this woman now is a US
senator but there's a problem which is
that she is the senator from California
but she doesn't live in California she
lives in Maryland and if you go to the
website of Emily's List her her Maryland
residence was listed there until they
scrubbed it in
mid-september Rob Pyers who's research
director of the California Target book
looks at all these Finance filings uh
this woman was listed as being a
Maryland resident as recently is August
31st so is that going to take her out is
lansa Butler no longer going to be the
senator the senat Trix from
California uh no no one's going to Care
nobody's going to care at all
it used to be a really good attack in
politics to say that so and so is a
carpet bagger you know he just moved
from DC to this District so he could win
Congress that would sometimes work
doesn't really work anymore because
national identity and ideological
identity perhaps even more so has
overtaken State
identity and the first part of that was
actually predicted and encouraged by the
founding fathers and the framers in the
Federalist uh the the puus you know
who's an amalgam of Alexander Hamilton
and James Madison and John Jay they
wrote in the Federalist about how
initially in the early days of the
country State allegiances and State
identity are going to be tippity top but
then over time people are going to lose
a little bit of their flavor of their
state identity and take on more of a
national American identity well that's
happened no one really cares now you
know even for me if if there were a
really good conservative but he happened
not to be from my state but he could be
the senator for my state I'd strongly
consider voting for that
person what's a little dangerous though
not exactly encouraged by the founding
fathers and the framers is that
ideological identity has taken over
probably even American identities and
national identity such that probably The
Californians would be perfectly fine
having a senator from any country as
long as that Senator were fanatically uh
dedicated to killing babies and to all
the other nonsense on their agenda as
lefon Butler and as they are and that
does not strengthen American national
identity that threatens its very essence
today is theology Thursday we have a
very special guest my friend Tim Gordon
is going to be on the show to talk about
this story that many of you have written
about the Catholic church is heading
into the CID and cidality no one really
knows what this thing is but we're
seeing all these news reports that is
the church going to teach change
teaching on marriage is the church going
to change teaching on whether women can
be pre they can't be priests they can be
priestesses I guess and what what is
going on well I've brought on someone
who knows a lot more about it than I do
Tim Gordon the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
use code NES kwls a check out for two
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans